mobile task force operatives fire their
assault rifles at the approaching crowd
of scp-008 zombies only to be swarmed
and overwhelmed administrative staff try
to activate the communications arrays
and contact help from another site but
scp-106 has melted all the wiring
already keeping them cut off from the
outside world Abel is drawing his
obsidian blades to slice and dice some
unfortunate guards and scp-682 is
running rampant in the Halls devouring
everyone he sees in site 19 thanks to
the biggest Containment Breach in modern
record the inmates are now running the
Asylum the guards are no longer in
control the researchers have no
information and the administrative staff
is powerless this time the anomalies are
on top how will our heroes at the SCP
Foundation fare when the roles are
reversed first we joined Dr clef the
most trigger-happy researcher that the
SCP Foundation ever employed he never
met an anomaly he didn't propose to
terminate most of these anomalies he'd
be happy to tell to their faces he
wanted to terminate them this was a
decision he may have wanted to go back
on now that the roles were reversed and
he found himself strapped to a table
with a number of belts he struggled
against his restraints but it was no
good he was
tight standing above him was a d-class
possessed by a scp-035 the possessive
mask carrying one of Dr clef's favorite
shotguns a squad of cackling vengeful
members of d-class personnel stood
behind him egging him on the possessive
mask laughed and spoke Dr Alto Cliff I
have conferred with my associates the
esteemed members of the SCP foundation's
d-class personnel and in light of your
poor conduct belligerent nature and
repeated acts of excessive aggression
weeping continued containment would
present undue risks instead we recommend
immediate termination Dr klaff gold and
the possessive mask cocked his shotgun
elsewhere in the facility
scp-076-1 Abel The Immortal Warrior was
running some training simulations the
exact kind that mobile task force
operatives might run but with a 2 twist
this time it was Abel's training and he
was using some captive mobile Task Force
officers as training equipment he'd
taken away their guns and instead gave
every single one of them one of his
swords which it probably goes without
saying they weren't quite as Adept with
as he was not that Abel cared when he
was ready to begin his training
simulation he pulled out a blade in each
hand and jumped down into the training
area the sword wielding MTF operatives
were shaking in their boots as he
approached the biggest most Psychopathic
smile stretched across his face the
second that one of the MTF operatives
made the terrible mistake of raising his
sword and running in able effortlessly
parried him and the slaughter began by
the time this training simulation was
done Abel was the only Survivor and none
of the MTF operatives would later revive
themselves in a giant black sarcophagus
meanwhile scp-682 was working on a more
personal project one of the P
foundation's most enduring efforts was
attempting to terminate scp-682 at all
costs using some methods that even
hardcore sadists would describe as
exceptionally cruel and the
Irreplaceable Dr Jack Bright had
contributed more than his fair share of
potential killing methods including
using his anomalous Medallion to
forcibly insert his Consciousness into
scp-682's own but now that the roles
were reversed 682 wanted a little of
that sweet sweet payback after devouring
his fill of random researchers and
guards 682 decided to narrow his Focus
onto Dr bright that's exactly why he had
Dr bright hanging by his arms from a
pair of chains above the same tank of
acid that 682 had been wasting away in
for decades now 682 couldn't wait for Dr
bright to experience the pain he'd known
for so long well doctor we've tried
burning crushing and freezing and still
it seems we can give you a permanent
death we'll try the acid now I can tell
you from personal experience doctor this
acid is very very if effective 682
pulled the lever on the ground loosening
the chains around Dr Bright's arms as
the wisecracking researcher dropped down
towards the acid 682 felt a profound
sense of calm
scp-049 on the other hand was feeling a
profound sense of excitement after all
he'd spent months being experimented on
by low-level research staff after having
his own rights to research taken away
after a minor incident involving the
death and subsequent reanimation of
senior researcher Hamlin and now with
the tables turned and the roles reversed
everything was about to change 049 had a
whole gaggle of captured researchers
confined in the cell the perfect testing
stock for his next series of experiments
into the pestilence the play doctor
opened his bag and began taking out each
one of his frightening medical tools
laying them across a nearby table and
ignoring the cries of protests from the
cell he feels no pity for them they
should be honored to become part of such
a towering body of Rhys
their sacrifices would not be
meaningless as their deaths would
contribute to saving so many other lives
the exact same logic that the SCP
Foundation uses to justify every piece
of collateral damage that they've ever
incurred but as the plague doctor walks
towards the cell with a scalpel
wondering which of the terrified
researchers he'd select first none of
them really appreciated the irony
someone that did very much appreciate
irony was
scp-106 one of the most cruel
calculating and sadistic anomalies that
the foundation has ever had to contain
while he wasn't nearly as talkative as
some of the other Sapient humanoid
anomalies out there he was still
extremely intelligent and he'd been
observing methods that the SCP
Foundation had been using to contain him
for all these years the one he found the
most frustrating was their tendency to
make the area around his containment
cell extremely complicated knowing it
would confuse him and make it that much
harder for him to escape SCP 106 had
been planning his particular method of
role reversal for years and little by
little building it in his beloved pocket
Dimension as soon as the anomalies took
control of site 19
scp-106 captured a gaggle of researchers
and guards and dragged them to his
hellish pocket Dimension there he
trapped each one of them inside cells in
a Twisted version of Psych 19 as each
one tried to escape they found that they
were trapped in the same complex network
of obstacles they'd always use to keep
scp-106 contain the one differences in
this case they were being chased by a
cp106 and they weren't just playing for
their freedom they were playing for
their lives it was the most fun as cp106
had had in years but not all of the
anomalies subject to the mass site-19
role reversal were acting out violent
Revenge fantasies the anomalous Butler
Mr Deeds summoned up by the s
scp-662 Bell was enjoying a real change
of Peace under anomalous control during
the early hours of the Containment
Breach a researcher had rung the bell
and summoned Mr Deeds to help them
Control the Chaos but for some reason
Beyond anyone's understanding Mr Deeds
had simply refused the orders not
because they weren't possible as is the
case of his usual commands but because
today he simply did not feel like it and
if the foundation Personnel who summoned
him didn't want him to alert more
dangerous anomalies of their presence
they needed to wait on him for a change
it's not like they had any choice in the
matter this time that's why Mr Deeds was
reclining in the comfiest chair they
could find sipping on a pina colada and
getting a foot massage from a nervous
Junior researcher even the anomaly who
devoted his entire life to service was
on this special day deciding to take a
load off and treat himself to some much
needed rest and relaxation and who could
blame him really
scp-1370 on the other hand was choosing
to make war rather than love typically
this tiny pathetic automaton known as
pesterbot was little more than an
amusingly useless sentient toy with
delusions of grandeur he wasn't an
anomaly that anyone took seriously and
even fewer people feared him in short
scp-1370 was perhaps The Biggest Loser
in all the foundation's containment but
now that the roles had been reversed he
wasn't so pathetic anymore during the
initial chaos of the Containment Breach
while all the security Personnel was
distracted by the significantly more
dangerous anomalies the pesterbot
somehow managed to sneak his way into
the experimental weapons lab that's
where he got his hands on a 40 watt
phased plasma rifle which promptly fused
to his little robot arm allowing him to
enact a spree of chaotic shootings
across his section of the site he
cackled in his tinny robotic voice as
guards and researchers fled from him he
leveled his plasma rifle and fired
glowing hot
in all directions while declaring
himself to be the immutable mecha lord
of all creation and when he had such a
deadly tool in his hands one that with a
single shot could superheat your
skeleton into radioactive Ash nobody
dared to dispute such a claim oh how the
tables had turned but those weren't the
only researchers in deep trouble the
grand role reversal had resulted in a
lot of researchers with less than
ethical scientific conduct getting a
frightening Taste of their own medicine
this is exactly what happened when a
gang of the infamous laughing men as CP
2419 the vengeful bodies of soulless
d-class Personnel managed to get their
hands on the dog-bodied senior
researcher Dr Kane pathos Crow Dr Crow
had always been an aggressive user of
scp-158 also known as the soul extractor
using this machine he had ripped out the
souls of many d-classes as part of his
frowned upon Olympia project naturally
this role reversal would not result in
Doc Crow getting a favorable outcome
instead three laughing men forced him
into the soul extractor which promptly
removed his soul and placed it into a
jar a jar which The Laughing Man then
decided to play a round of catch with
and honestly as adorable as he may be I
don't think there's any denying that Dr
Crow had this one coming maybe don't
extract so many people's Souls next time
doctor but for some anomalies the role
reversal was not a time for relaxation
rampaging or Revenge it was a time for
personal development this was the case
for scp-2430 the immortal Hitler clone
with all the chaos that was going on The
Daily staff Hitler punching roster had
fallen by the wayside allowing the
anomalous ex-dictator to leave his cell
for once and wander around the facility
eventually he found himself in a room
he'd never been in before the site 19
employee Library which featured a wide
range of both anomalous and
non-anomalous texts this was where he
found and decided out of sheer curiosity
City to read a variety of personal
development and anti-racism books that
taught him the error of his ways for the
first time and in what was perhaps the
biggest role reversal of the entire
breach he began to realize that the
philosophy of discrimination he'd held
in his previous life had hurt millions
of people and put him on the road to
nowhere but before he could go any
further down the road of
self-development the long-awaited
Cavalry arrived the fact that psych 19
had dropped out of contact with other
nearby sites for over 10 hours had
raised alarm Bells with the o5 council
who dispatched a wide array of mobile
task forces to save the terrorized
populace of Psych 19 and return
Foundation control all of the day's wall
reversals were re-reversed back into
their original state that's right
everything had been returned to normal
for now anyway now go check out Rick and
Morty more powerful than the SCP
Foundation mad scientist battle and
scp-343 God vs Bill Cipher from Gravity
Falls for more